ojo jojo es sieht wirklich verdammt
danach aus dass kosmologische
standardmodell hängt und es sind so
stark dass es wahrscheinlich schon bald
erwiesenermaßen ad acta gelegt werden
muss ein totaler fail wissenschaftler
haben jetzt nämlich herausgefunden dass
galaxien gar nicht so aufgebaut sind wie
das standardmodell voraussagt und damit
existiert auch die dunkle materie nicht
und die dunkle energie ist auch gleich
mit entsorgt wie konnte das passieren
jetzt den klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja so sieht es aus wenn die physik
grundlegend auf den kopf gestellt wird
hier erklären oliver müller und
frederico laely was sie gefunden haben
und das ist mehr als bahnbrechend er
sieht schwer daraus dass das
kosmologische standardmodell makulatur
ist einfach nicht stimmt dunkle materie
und dunkle energie gibt es gar nicht
aber der reihe nach wie ist denn die
physik überhaupt darauf gekommen dass es
dunkle materie geben könnte
in der astrophysik wurde bei galaxien
etwas sehr seltsames entdeckt die
äußeren arme drehten sich schneller um
das zentrum als eigentlich möglich gebe
es nur normale materie würden alle
galaxien sofort auseinander fliegen die
fliehkraft würde sie zerreißen aber was
hält sie dann zusammen die erklärung war
die dunkle materie wäre sie in einem
bestimmten verhältnis vorhanden würde
sie die galaxien zusammen halten es gäbe
mehr dunkle materie als die materie die
wir kennen jetzt gab es aber noch ein
problem
die dunkle materie bildet zu langsam
strukturen computersimulationen sagen
ein viel schnelleres wachstum voraus
etwas musste sie abbremsen schwupps da
war auch schon die dunkle energie da
jetzt gibt es aber ein problem mit den
beiden sie wurden nicht gefunden und in
der teilchenphysik gibt es noch nicht
einmal irgendwelche kandidaten für
solche teilchen und jetzt kommt aber
eben der hammer alle bisher untersuchten
galaxien entsprechen nicht dem
kosmologischen standardmodell noch mal
langsam zum mitschreiben nicht
eigentlich müsste asics zwerggalaxien
verstreut um jede galaxie geben
kugelförmig so sagt es das kosmologische
standardmodell voraus tun sie aber nicht
erst mal sind es nicht ich sondern viel
weniger und sie sind nicht verstreut
sondern sie liegen auch in der ebene der
galaxie drehen sich also wie die
planeten in unserem sonnensystem in
einer ebene um das zentrum jedenfalls
die meisten und das widerspricht dem
kosmologischen standardmodell boom
jetzt haben marcel pawlowski oliver
müller von ricoh rallye und hell
modellieren die galaxie centaurus a
untersucht es ist die dritte galaxie die
dem standardmodell widerspricht viel
zugeordnet rotieren hier die
zwerggalaxien um die haupt galaxie eben
in der rotation ebene von centaurus a
mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit
einigkeit ist damit das kosmologische
standardmodell widerlegt es müsste schon
ein wahnwitziger zufall sein
wenn schon die dritte galaxie zufällig
etwas besonderes wäre es spricht also
vieles wenn nicht alles dafür dass das
kosmologische standardmodell so nicht
funktioniert falsch ist eine nie
bewiesene hypothese jetzt auch widerlegt
wurde
denn das ist ihr wichtig dieses standard
wurde war bisher eine hypothese die es
zu beweisen galt was jetzt wiederum
nicht gelungen ist und die menge der in
diez sind die jetzt dagegen sprechen die
werden immer erdrückender für pavel
kroupa von der universität bonn und
doktorvater von pawlowski ist alles klar
zitat wir erleben ein wissenschaftliches
erdbeben er sieht die dunkle materie
damit als widerlegt und mahnt eine
reform des gravitationsgesetz anja das
ist der absolute wahnsinn
aber was ist es das die galaxien
zusammenhält ich hatte ja schon mal über
schwarze löcher spekuliert die sehr viel
mehr geben soll als bisher gedacht oder
gestern die kosmischen strings die ja
offensichtlich unglaubliche mengen an
masse enthalten es wird also bald
ziemlich spannend wenn dieses rätsel
gelöst wird wenn er als erstes neues zu
diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video also vorab
garantiert ihr könnt dann direkt in der
redaktion folglich zum mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen oder andere ideen der
direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
dunkle materie rätsel löst spielen
schwarze löcher eine rolle
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran